Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim!
Blauer Linus, was verspricht eigentlich am meisten politische Stabilität? Logbuchnetzpolitik Nr. 444.
Ein bisschen Schnaps heute in der Sendung. Das ist der erste Tag der Nr. 444.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nr. 444. Logbuchnetzpolitik Nr. 444.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nr. 444. Ein bisschen Schnaps heute in der Sendung.
Vom 22.10.22. Logbuchnetzpolitik Nr. 444.
Wow, 4, 2, 2, 1, 2, 2, 2...
Ja. Zahlen, Mystik und Magie.
Das ist doch hier eine Botschaft.
Na ja, ja, da wusstest du, dass wenn man Lokbuchnetzbüchern zurückwärts hört, dass da auch satanische Botschaften drin vorkommen.
Ja klar, ich mach dir da ja extra rein, was für schwierig das ist.
Ja, das ist nicht, ich geb mir auch immer richtig Mühe. Hat aber bisher noch keiner entdeckt. Mal gucken. Mensch, ihr Höhlerin, ihr seid doch sonst immer so pfiffig. Habt ihr noch nie rausgekriegt.
Aber die Botschaften wirken ja subliminal, die wirken ja trotzdem. Die werden nicht wahrgenommen, aber...
Genau, die richtigen Thesen packen wir unter 20 Hz.
Hehehe.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, Salat ist die Zukunft der politischen Stabilität. Da kann man sich noch was von versprechen.
Ich könnte mir auch die eine oder andere politische Personale vorstellen, die ich mal gegen Salat antreten lassen würde.
Ja.
Veggie Day!
Der politikal veggie day genau wer die anspielung noch nicht verstanden hat also groß britannien hat ja jetzt wieder mal eine premierministerin verbraucht
die distrust hat mal gerade mal sechs wochen gehalten wo man auch sagen muss davon hat sie eigentlich nur vier wochen zeit gehabt wirklich irgendwie zu regieren ja.
Wirklich die britische wirtschaft in kompletten untergang zu richten und da war sie sehr gut.
Wobei das Problem ist, dass sie im Wesentlichen das getan hat, was sie vorher angekündigt hat, was sie tun wird.
Anfängerfehler.
Ja, und alle so, naja, okay, gut, das sagst du jetzt, aber das machst du natürlich dann später nicht. Und dann hat sie das dann trotzdem gemacht und die merkte so...
Ja, und dann war es vorbei mit ihr und wenn wir jetzt ein bisschen Pech haben, dann können wir sogar Boris Johnson wieder zurück ist. Das ist wirklich zum Schreien.
Also Großbritannien macht sich echt so dermaßen zum Ömmel. Das ist wirklich einfach echt nicht mehr zu fassen.
Alle Details dazu übrigens in der aktuellen UKW-Folge, wo ich mal wieder mit John Wurst die letzten drei Monate zusammengekehrt habe.
Und es ist...
Aber die war ja noch prä-trust niederlagege.
Ja, also ich habe die Sendungsaufnahme beendet und zehn Minuten später kam dann die Nachricht.
Ja, aber er sagt ja auch so. Wenn List Trust in heutigen Tag überlebt, dann ist sie morgenfällig.
Genau, insofern haben wir schon unser Money.
Wir haben ja Feedback provoziert. Feedback-Bating, in dem wir uns zu Baden-Geschichten als inkompetent und verständlich losgezeichnet haben. Ich mich zumindest. Also haben sich ganz viele
Bahn-Nerds wie erhofft bei uns gemeldet, um jetzt die Qualität unserer Berichterstattung zu erhöhen. Das ist echt gut. Ja, ist doch super.
Ja, ja, ja, also ich würde da jetzt auch für mich nicht zu viel Kompetenz in Anspruch nehmen wollen, habe ich nicht. Aber mir war jetzt mir schon mal vorher klar, dass wir da sicherlich nicht bei allem ganz richtig liegen,
beziehungsweise es noch einer gewissen Detailerläuterung braucht.
Dazu meldete sich unter anderem Christoph und schrieb mittlerer Barnerd hier. Die Geschehnisse zum...
Haben die sogar Stufen.
Es gibt da, ja klar natürlich, du musst da aufsteigen, also gibt dann getroht bis zum Platinlevel.
Ja, okay, ja super. Ich bin eher so Konsumentenende, Bahnbonus oder wie das heißt.
Normal privilegiert sozusagen ok also mittlerer bahn hört hier die geschehnisse zum gsm r ausfall hat sich der bahn youtuber alvin meschelt so gut zusammen gereimt dass sie db gebeten hat das video
offline zu nehmen ich versuche mal eure frage zeichen mit dem wissen aus diesem video zu füllen was ist gsm r gsm r ist erstmal stink normales gsm also das mobil funk netz das ursprüngliche digitale.
Das um ein paar sonder dienste ergänzt wurde zum beispiel gruppen und notruf sowie orts abhängige kurzwahlen für den nächsten fahrdienstleister für linus der typ auf dem stillwerk es dient.
Hauptsächlich der kommunikation zwischen lockführer und außenwelt man kann über gsm r auch daten übertragen der standard dazu nennt sich euro radio fährt ein zug ohne gsm r da die db den
etc s ausbau im wesentlichen verkackt hat sind in deutschland größtenteils nur ältere zugbeinflusungs systeme im einsatz die nicht auf gsm r angewiesen sind linus hat also recht die zugekönnen technisch
fahren allerdings können keine notrufe empfangen oder abgesetzt werden und das war der db anscheinend zu heiß obwohl es eine rückfallebene auf normales gsm gibt nur strecken die mit etc s level 2 im db
jagon etc s ohne signale ausgestattet sind benötigen wie von tim beschrieben euro radio um unter anderem die fahrerlaubnisse zu übertragen warum fällt gsm r in norddeutschland aus wenn man
zwei glasphasen in berlin und herne kappt die db betreibt in hanover ein msc also ein mobile services switching center aus ges im netz für norddeutschland kupien vom hr dem hohen
location register liegen in berlin und frankfurt die glasphasen haben das msc mit je eine hr kupi verbunden was passiert wenn ein msc das hr nicht mehr erreicht weiß linus besser als ich
weiß du das besser als er.
Ja klar also MSC ist im Prinzip so eine. Also Mobilfunknetze sind ja in Zellen, deswegen heißen die in den in den USA ja auch Cellular Network und du hast also das MSC.
Weiß nicht, wenn ihr zum großen Mobilfunkbetreiber hast, der hat halt ein paar davon in ganz Deutschland, für Regionen oder sowas. Vielleicht, keine Ahnung, so fünf bis sieben oder könnte auch noch mehr sein, wäre da so eine Zahl.
Dann hast du die Base Station Controller an die wiederum mehrere BTSn Base Trincea Stations angebunden sind. Also es ist im Prinzip wie so ein Baum, kannst du dir das vorstellen.
Das HLA ist das Home Location Register. Da sind im Prinzip die berechtigten Identitäten drin. Also wenn du dich jetzt mit dem Mobilfunknetz verbindest und dich da authentifizierst über Kies deiner SIM-Karte,
dann ist im HLA unter anderem wird geprüft, dass du eine Subscriberin bist und zum Beispiel auch weitere Dinge wie ob du jetzt gerade ROMs und solche Dinge haben.
Das heißt, das HLA ist schon so die zentrale, die eine zentrale Komponente, die so ein Mobilfunknetz hat. Also HLA heißt das in 2G, in 3G, 4G, 5G heißen die dann immer ein bisschen anders, haben aber immer die gleiche Funktion.
Kannst dir vorstellen, wie die zentrale Nutzer in Datenbank. Wenn du jetzt zwischen MSC und HLA keine Verbindung hast, dann kann sich niemand mehr an dem Ding anmelden.
Weil der MSC eben die ganzen Authentication Request und auch potentielle Rootinginformationen und so weiter nicht mehr der zentralen Verwaltung zuführen kann, sodass es wahrscheinlich allgemein verständlich ist, auszudrücken.
Genau, also diese Verbindung wurde sozusagen gekappt und dann kann man sich einfach nicht mehr einloggen. Dann kann man auch nicht mehr telefonieren.
Genau, also dann ist ja, dann ist es schlecht.
Weiter im Kommentar. Woher haben die Saboteure das gewusst? Die DB hatte das Rückfallkonzept für GSMR ins Netz gestellt. Er schreibt hier noch bei Archive.org sei es noch zu finden, ist es mittlerweile auch nicht mehr.
Wenn ich raten müsste, war es aufgrund der Netzneutralität. Das Netz der DB muss diskriminierungsfreien Mitbewerber angeboten werden, öffentlich zugänglich. Weitere Spekulationen von mir, die nicht in Hannover, sondern in Herne und Berlin manipuliert wurden, waren wahrscheinlich alle MSCs der DB-Ziel des Ganzen.
Zum Glück wussten die Saboteure wohl nicht, welche Glasfaser wohin führen, sonst wäre nicht nur Hannover ausgefallen. Ich habe auch noch mal geguckt, dieses PDF ist tatsächlich noch im Netz zu finden an anderen Orten.
Die Bahn hat dem YouTuber Alvin Meschel gesagt, ihr könnt hier mal ein Video runternehmen, wozu er nicht unbedingt gezwungen wäre. Aber hat es trotzdem gemacht.
Naja, wie auch immer, das jetzt mal die Hintergründe aus diesem Kommentar.
Weiterer Kommentar zu der Thematik von Kau. Zu der Kabel-Durchflex-Thematik eine kleine Anekdote.
In den späten 90ern habe ich in einer deutschen Großstadt mit Freunden nicht angemeldete Technopathies veranstaltet.
In leer stehenden Gebäuden unter Autobahnenbrücken etc. Location Scouting war ein wichtiger Teil dieser Aktivität.
Da kriegt man schon mal Sachen zu sehen, die normale Menschen normalerweise nicht sehen. Unter anderem ein unterirdischer Fernwärmetunnel, der kilometerlang von einem Heizwerk bis zum Hauptbahnhof führte.
Von dem kann man in die Keller einiger leer stehender Gebäude herein, an denen der Tunnel vorbeiführte.
Alles unverschlossen freizugänglich, wenn man wusste wo. In einem Raum, der von dem Tunnel ausging, stießen wir auf einen fetten Kabelstrang mit bestimmt 1,5 Metern Durchmesser.
Durch den vermute ich mal der komplette Telekomverkehr besagter Großstadt ging. Wir wollten nur Party, also haben wir da schön unsere Finger von gelassen.
Aber wir haben uns schon mal gefragt, was passiert, wenn da mal ein nicht so netter Mensch mit einer dicken Flex vorbeikommt.
Ja, ja, die Infrastruktur. Das ist auch alles gar nicht so einfach zu schützen.
Und ich bin jetzt aus dem Kommentar raus, das ist meine Anmerkung. Das ist natürlich jetzt ein generelles Problem, weil ich glaube auch viel davon so ein bisschen auf der Gesamtzivilisiertheit der Gesellschaft beruht.
Natürlich könnten wir unsere gesamte Infrastruktur innerhalb von Minuten komplett in den Schutt und Asche legen.
So viel Schutz kannst du dagegen gar nicht aufbringen. Die Frage ist halt immer nur, was ist ein angemessener und erforderlicher notwendiger Schutz?
Aber solche Wege könnte man vielleicht schon mal abgehen.
Ja, ich hatte auch noch von einem Kollegen das Feedback bekommen, weil ich gesagt habe, naja, okay, wenn du zwei Fasern hast, dann hast du halt zwei Fasern. Da wurde mir auch widersprochen, dass man natürlich im Sinne von Redundanzkonzepten eigentlich natürlich eine Netzwerkinfrastruktur so bauen will.
Dass sie ja potenziell alternative Routen sich einfach suchen kann, solange noch irgendwo irgendetwas erreichbar ist.
Und da gibt es ja diesen schönen alten, diese schöne alte Weisheit, die Internet Detect Censorship as Damage and Routes Around It. Ich habe mich allerdings, muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen, mit diesem GSMR nicht so ausreichend auseinandergesetzt,
dass ich wüsste, sagen wir mal, zu welchen Preisen und Aufwendungen das jetzt, also ob man das technisch mit Alternativ Links zu vertretbaren Preisen hinbekommen hätte, oder ob man, ja, oder ob das halt sehr, sehr teuer gewesen wäre.
Aber das, ich wurde ermahnt, dass wenn zwei Kabel kaputt sind, dass das jetzt nicht unbedingt ein ausreichendes Schutzniveau einer kritischen Infrastrukturkomponente ist. Aber ich kann also dem Stimmigpotenzial zu, aber da muss man eben berücksichtigen, welche Möglichkeiten haben die.
Da hat die Bahn erstmal relativ viele, also die profitieren ja durchaus davon, dass ihnen überall diese Strecken in Deutschland gehören, wo sie natürlich dann auch ohne Ende Glasfasern und was nicht alles reinwerfen können und so Infrastruktur in Deutschland legen können.
Aber ich kann mich jetzt, bin nicht auf dem Niveau in dieses Thema eingestiegen, dass ich jetzt beurteilen könnte und sagen könnte, ich habe das auf für so und so viel tausend Euro, hättet ihr, oder 100.000 Euro, dieses Problem potenziell überhaupt niemals gehabt.
So, dann haben wir natürlich in den letzten Sendungen sehr viel über diese Gematik-TI-Infrastruktur gesprochen. Insbesondere jetzt hier mit unserem Spezial, mit Flübcke. Aber auch vorher war ja das Ehrezept schon ein Thema.
Und damit natürlich dieser gesamte Komplex. Da sind also jetzt verschiedene Kommentare aus den letzten Sendungen, wo wir mal ein paar herausgegriffen haben, die hier unter Umständen das Ganze noch etwas weiter erleuchten.
Lukas schrieb, moin zusammen, vielen Dank für eure ausführliche Beleuchtung der TI und insbesondere der EPA. Zur Erinnerung, das ist die elektronische Patientnagde.
Zur EPA ist zu sagen, dass die abgelegten Dokumente keineswegs in einem beliebigen Typen vorliegen dürfen. Explizit sind PDF, JPEG, TIFF, TXT, RTF, JPEG, PNG und FHIR plus XML. Das sind diese Health Records.
Sind erlaubt. Der angesprochene Upload von Wörth-Dokumenten mit Makros ist also nicht möglich. Schon mal beruhigend, oder? Die zugrunde liegenden Daten sind aktuell zwar leider noch unnötig häufig, nicht maschinenlesbare PDFs, werden aber in zunehmenden Maße als sogenannte MIOs, also medizinische Informationsobjekte, abgelegt.
Also das ist dieses FHIR-Format, was da erwähnt wurde. Und MIOs scheint jetzt nochmal so ein Begriff zu sein, der in...
Ja, in Deutschland, die jetzt nochmal gekoint wird. Fast Healthcare Interoperability Resources, das ist dieses FHIR, das ist das auch was so ein iPhone macht und so weiter.
Das ist schon so der Standard, in dem man medizinische Daten inkudiert. Weiter im Kommentar.
Diese Dokumente sind dann von Primärsystemen, durchaus maschinenlesbar und übersichtlich abzubilden, auch wenn die Realität im Frontend der Primärsysteme davon noch weit entfernt ist.
Danke für euren Humor zu so frustrierenden Themen. Okay, kein Wort.
HospitalITGuy schreibt, hallo zunächst sehr herzlichen Dank für den großartigen Podcast im Allgemeinen und diese großartige Folge im Speziellen, das bezog sich jetzt auf die Sendung mit Flübcke, da ihr es nicht erwähnt habt, noch ein kleines Detail.
Die Kisten stehen auch bei uns in den Kliniken. Wir dürften so in etwa 60 von denen noch zur Konfiguration im Lager haben, plus 10, die bereits eingesetzt werden.
Die Realität sieht so aus, dass sich seit einigen Monaten ein Kollege ausschließlich mit diesem Thema herumschlagen muss und dementsprechend für nichts anderes mehr zur Verfügung stehen kann.
Wie man sich sicher vorstellen kann, sind wir im öffentlichen Dienst weder qualitativ noch quantitativ gut besetzt und werden gerade mit Themen zugeschüttet, die kaum noch zu erledigen sind.
Wie die Digitalisierung in den Kliniken mit der aktuellen Personalsituation umgesetzt werden soll, ist mir jedenfalls völlig schleierhaft.
Er sagt jetzt leider nicht, ob sich hier um so ein öffentliches Krankenhaus oder ein privates handelt, aber letzten Endes ist das Problem natürlich immer das Gleiche, was wir auch so am Rande angesprochen haben.
So diese generelle Frage von wer muss jetzt eigentlich wofür der Kompetenz haben und überfordert die Digitalisierung, sozusagen die Leute, die davon profitieren sollen.
Ist sie zu kompliziert einzuführen? Und mich wundert das jetzt so ein bisschen, dass für diese Kisten dann 2400 Euro bezahlt werden muss, die irgendwie 150 Euro Hardware-Wert haben und da müssen sie das auch noch selber einrichten.
Ja, also, Gematik ist kein Wunschkonzert.
Und das sind die Kisten, die dann noch mehr viel bezahlt werden müssen.
Das mit Sicherheit nicht. Nun, nun, weiter im Text auch Psychodoc hat noch einen Kommentar für uns zur selben Sendung.
Mir ist als Arzt durchaus bewusst, dass eine Digitalisierung im deutschen Gesundheitswesen notwendig ist, wobei diese vor allem die Patienten und die Leistungserbringer im Alltag unterstützen sollte. Die derzeitigen Dienste nutzen eher den Krankenkassen.
Da würde ich gerne auch nochmal einen Haken. Niemand sagt, dass das nicht so sein sollte.
Es ist ja ein gerne gemachter Vorwurf oder eine gerne gemachte Unterstellung, die denjenigen, die sich hier für ein Mindestmaß an Qualität und Sicherheit einsetzen,
dass sie die Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens verhindern würden, bis hin zu, was weiß ich, der sterben Menschen.
Das ist in letzter Zeit so ein sehr häufig vorgebrachtes Argument.
Was wir gerne hätten, wäre ja einfach nur ein Mindestmaß an IT-Sicherheit. Und ich glaube, da geht der Kommentar von PsycoDocke jetzt auch hin.
Ich wollte nur nochmal kurz meine absolute Unterstützung für diese Aussage nennen. Und natürlich denke ich, da kann ich auch für Flip-Gesprächen, dass er jetzt kein Gegner einer Digitalisierung des Gesundheitswesens wäre.
Und ich glaube, das ist wahrscheinlich ein Gleichwort. Das wollte ich nur nochmal, so stark beizulichten.
Ja, ist klar. Weiter im Text. Die elektronische Arbeitsunfähigkeitsbescheinigung, kurz EU, das elektronische Rezept, das E-Rezept und KIM Kommunikation in der Medizin, der verschlüsselte E-Mail-Dienst, laufen bei mir noch nicht, da mein IT-Dienstleister auf Avaato wartet.
Avaato ist nochmal ein anderer Dienstleister, oder? Die elektronische Patientinakte EPA wollte bislang keine Patientin bzw. kein Patient und ich persönlich kann auch keinem dazu raten vertrauliche Gesundheitsdaten zentral speichern zu lassen.
Übrigens gibt es demnächst eine Online-Veranstaltung der Kassenärztlichen Bundesvereinigung, KWV, wo ein von der Münch-Stiftung und der Bertelsmann-Stiftung in Auftrag gegebenes Rechtsgutachten zur Option Out-Regelung der EPA vorgestellt wird.
Bei den Auftraggebern wird sicher das richtige Ergebnis dabei rauskommen. Richtig in Anführungsstrichen.
Der versicherten Stammdatenabgleich, also Name, Versicherungsnummer, Anschrift, Krankenkassen über die Telematik läuft zwar, ist aber immer noch nicht zuverlässig in der Durchführung.
In der Praxis gibt es vielfältige Probleme, z.B. ein Chipmangel, der die Ausgabe der elektronischen Gesundheitskarten verzögert.
Einige Krankenkassen bieten ihren Versicherten an, online sich selbst eine Ersatzbescheinigung auszustellen. Das lässt noch mal Blicken auf.
Durchführungsschwierigkeiten. Letzter Kommentar zu der Thematik haben dann, oder war nicht der letzte Kommentar, weil der letzte, den wir jetzt zitieren, ist von Markus. Auch zur selben Sendung. Hi, sehr gute Sendung und größtenteils sehr gute Darstellung der Verhältnisse in der TI.
Ein paar Punkte hätte ich dann noch. Die Idee, private Schlüssel in die Hände von Versicherten zu geben, hat auch so ihre Tücken. EGKs, also elektronische Gesundheitskarte, werden mit Wechsel der Krankenkasse sowieso regelmäßig bei Verlust neu ausgestellt.
Was passiert dann mit denen auf der Basis der obsoleten EGK verschüsselten Dokumente? So eine elektronische Patientenakte hält ja ein Leben lang, was schon mal 90 Jahre plus sein kann.
Auch Vertreterregelungen müssen berücksichtigt werden. Also Patienten, Entpflegeeinrichtungen etc. gesetzliche Vertreterinnen, Vormo- und Versorgungsberichtiger. Alle müssen natürlich Zugriff auf so eine Akte dann haben. Klar, so was lässt sich vermutlich anders als jetzt regeln.
Aber so einfach wie nimmt das Zettifikat Schlüssel aus der EGK und alles wird gut, ist es dann auch nicht. Es muss für die normale Versicherte benutzbar und verstehbar bleiben, ohne für die Kassen zu einem allzu großen Supportfall auszuatmen.
Genau, meine Daten sind weg, ich habe meine Gesundheitskarte verloren, helfen sie mir und so weiter Daten wieder herstellen. Das ist in der Tat ein echtes Problem. Die Leute schaffen es ja nicht mal die Messenger von einem aufs nächste Handy zu migrieren, ohne einen neuen Account anzulegen.
Aufseiten der Betreiber wird aktuell sichergestellt, dass kein Einzelner an die Daten kommt und schon gar nicht wie bei euch angedeutet über Ausstellung der Schüssel in den SGDs. Was ist das?
Schlüsselgenerierungsdiensten.
Ah, ja genau. Dazu braucht es mehrere Menschen, die sich verbünden und die über das passende Wissen verfügen. Einfach wäre da vermutlich ein Angriff über die elektronische Gesundheitskarte
oder die ALVI, die Alternative Versicherten-Identität, ein Verfahren, eine Patienten-Aktion zu bekommen ohne diese Gesundheitskarte. Aber dann hat man ein einzelnes EPA-Spannender, wäre etwas mit dem man an viele
EPAs kommt. Einzelne EPAs oder Patienten-Daten greift man einfacher bei den Ärzten ab. Die Praxen sind eher lasch beim Thema Datenschutz und Sicherheit. Ja, war jetzt ein bisschen kompliziert.
Niemand sagt, dass es einfach ist, aber jeder kann dir sagen, was falsch ist. Und diese SGDs, wo halt das Input, um das Geheimnis zu bekommen für die Verschlüsselung.
Im Prinzip öffentliche Informationen sind, hast ja eine direkte Übersetzung von im Prinzip eine Nummer in ein KIE ohne weiterer Authentifizierung.
Ich denke, das sollte aber auch ein klar sein, dass das so nicht geht. Klar, potentiell musst du, wenn Leute neue Karten haben, die Inhalte der IPA umschlüsseln oder eben mit neuen zugänglich machen.
Aber das kann man alles anders lösen als mit einer Verschlüsselung, die am Ende keine ist. Weil wenn du eine Verschlüsselung hast, die am Ende keine ist, wo es auch keine Verschlüsselung zu machen.
Ich würde der Vollständigkeit halber, also vielleicht noch kurzer Punkt, dieser Gematik, wie wir jetzt lernen, sehr viel Geld.
Und da kann man auch für ein schwieriges Problem eine Lösung erwarten, statt eine Auseinandersetzung mit einem Problem erwarten, statt einfach zu sagen,
ah nee, das ist schwer, das lösen wir jetzt einfach, indem wir ganz viel Geld nehmen, um am Ende etwas zu bauen, was das Problem nicht löst.
Das ist, denke ich, auch nicht akzeptabel. Ich wollte noch ganz kurz sagen, es gab natürlich auch Reaktionen auf Flipkiss,
Veröffentlichungen mit dem CCC und den anderen Mitwirkenden, die wir auch alle nochmal gelistet haben.
Und das war im Prinzip zwei Dinge. Ja, du, das ist eine Operation am offenen Herzen, die hat noch nie jemand gemacht, als wäre noch nie ein Zertifikat verlängert worden auf dem Planeten.
Boiler findet täglich überall statt.
Und genau, viele täglich über Altstadt, alles ist überhaupt kein Problem. Und vor allem, dann damit verbunden, uns läuft ja jetzt die Zeit weg,
weil ihr fünf Jahre vergammelt habt.
Nicht weil jetzt plötzlich, also dieses Problem, also muss ich ja dazu sagen, dieses Problem ist seit fünf Jahren bekannt,
oder was heißt, ich würde sagen, wahrscheinlich betrachten, ist die Hersteller nicht als Problem, sondern als Geldsegen.
Die freuen sich auf das Geld schon seit langem. Insofern wurde das Problem ja bewusst nicht angegangen. Es gab ja dann auch, was Flipke erzählt hatte, diese zwei Hersteller, Sekundett war der eine, die eine Lösung sogar vorgeschlagen haben.
Und dann, ihr habt aber in der Gematik gesagt, ach nee, komm, lass mal. Und dann sind sie eben alle auf das, na okay, dann machen wir nur das, was wir ein bisschen zurückgefallen.
Weil sie wahrscheinlich auch keinen Bock hatten, dass dann die CGM als einzig das nicht macht und dafür auch noch fett finanziell belohnt wird.
Also, Operation um offenen Herzen ist Quatsch. Und das mit dem Zeitdruck, der jetzt natürlich gewissermaßen herrscht.
Ist auch sehr wohlfall weil der ja nur dadurch kommt dass das problem einfach nicht angegangen seid ja und man kann sich natürlich immer hinstellen und sagen man geht ein problem nicht an.
Bis bis die hütte kurz vom brand steht und dann sagen ja also leute sehen es kriegen wir es auch nicht mehr hin also der kürze hätte aber mal früher kommen müssen und dieses problem ist aber jetzt
auch nicht erst ne es wird nicht also es wird nicht erst seit was was ich seit einem jahr oder seit einem halben jahr bestritten dass das was die was die da fordern oder gemacht haben dass das
dass das nicht in ordnung ist ja das wird ja schon seit längerem so behandelt nur jetzt mal flübkes beitrag war dann nachdem er die dinger aufgemacht hat zu nochmal den wirklichen
beweis anzutreten weil solange ja die dinger quasi geschlossen da stehen und die irgendwelche behauptungen machen ja oder auch bei heise war ja ich glaube vor Monaten schon auch ein klarer
bericht darüber so das kann man tauschen und dann sagen die man nene das geht nicht und da spielt ist der beitrag eben schon einfach zu sagen doch es geht wir haben es gebaut hier da ist genau eure
software hier sind die part sein kommt mit der man das ändern muss es geht hört aufzulügen das ist der der einer aspekt und dann das argument was sie vortragen ist ja du das sind.
Ja aber fünf jahre alte konnektoren das ist ja in der computer in der in der in der computer welt ist das ja eine halbe ewigkeit da muss man ja mal was neues hinstellen und auch dieses argument ist natürlich total beknackt.
Weil es sind VPN-Router, die haben also die einzige technische Limitation, die die haben, ist im Prinzip, wie viel Cipher oder wie viel können die Pro-Zeiteinheit verschlüsseln,
um quasi den Traffic aufrecht zu erhalten.
Also wenn du den jetzt technisch besser machst, mit einem neueren Prozessor oder so, dann wird der einzige Zugewinn, den du haben wirst, dass das Ding mehr Datenmenge pro Zeiteinheit übertragen und verschlüsseln kann.
So, jetzt sind wir aber nicht in einem Land, wo, also sagen wir, in vielen Arztpraxen würde ich jetzt mal die vorsichtige These anstellen, dass der VPN, ein 5 Jahre alter VPN-Router
mehr pro Sekunde verschlüsseln kann, als die DSL-Leitung übertragen kann.
So, es stimmt, da gibt es Grenzen. Ja, ich meine, ich betreibe ja auch Poppenrouter.
Ich habe, so wenn du da jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, über 40 Ambit kommen willst oder so, dann werden die Dinge auch mal ein bisschen teurer.
So, aber das ist, das wäre ja immer, also selbst wenn all das so wäre, ja, könnten ja die Praxen immer noch sagen, na ja, pass auf, bisher konnten wir nicht feststellen.
Dass dieser Router ein Bottleneck war und unsere digitalen Prozesse hier verlangsamt hätte.
Insofern entscheiden wir uns im Rahmen unseres unternehmerischen Risikos über uns an weiterhin diesen fünf Jahre alten Router anzuschließen.
Noch dazu muss man sagen, ganz klar, na, wenn man, also ich habe Poppenrouter, die sind sehr viel älter, ja, und mit denen bin ich sehr zufrieden.
Und wenn mir vor fünf Jahren etwas verkauft worden wäre, was ich nach fünf Jahren nicht mehr gebrauchen kann, während sich ja in der Internetgeschwindigkeit in Deutschland überhaupt nichts verändert hat,
also dieses Argument macht auch einfach vorne und hinten keinen Sinn, ist einfach, einfach nicht sinnvoll, ja.
Und selbst wenn es so wäre, ja, niemand von uns sagt, dass die Dinger noch 20 Jahre halten, aber keines dieser beiden Argumente reicht aus, um einen Zwangstausch, ne,
eine Zwangsverschrottung und Zwangsneuanschaffung dem deutschen Gesundheitssystem aufzulegen.
Vor allem für den Preis und ich gehe auch ehrlich gesagt nicht davon aus, dass die Geräte, die sie dann liefern in irgendeiner Form anders sind, als die, die da eh schon stehen.
Kap es, ja die werden irgendeinen neueren Chip haben und die werden wahrscheinlich auch zehn Prozent schneller sein oder könnten auch 20 sein. Ja, also da wird es sicherlich irgendwann mal Benchmarks geben oder so.
Aber es ist in keiner Form, in keiner Form akzeptabel. Ja, also zu dem Preis ohnehin nicht und also das ist alles von vorne bis hinten wirklicher Moogs.
Genau. Die Geräte sind nicht der Flaschenhals, der Flaschenhals seid ihr.
Ja.
So, jetzt haben wir noch eine schlechte Nachricht. Das das weiße mal hier.
He he he.
Wir hatten ja vor zwei Sennung.
Dann haben wir auf den Call for Participation für den 37 C3 hingewiesen.
Was da naheliegt, dass er dann stattfinden soll.
Genau, der CALL 4 Participation wurde jetzt wieder geschlossen. Es gab ein Orgertreffen, wo viele Menschen, die zum Kongress beitragen, teilgenommen haben.
Und im Rahmen dieses Gesprächs konnte keine realistische Möglichkeit gefunden werden. Wir haben einen C3 in Hamburg ausgerichtet.
Und entsprechend wurde die Entscheidung getroffen, das dann nicht zu tun. Entsprechend wird die nächste Großveranstaltung des Chaos Computer Clubs das Camp sein im nächsten Jahr.
Und das haben wir in diesem Rahmen dann auch angekündigt und freuen uns darauf.
So, jetzt gab's natürlich auch noch ein bisschen Fallout zu der Geschichte um Herrn Schönbom. Und so ein...
Und so ein... Ist er jetzt eigentlich schon ehemalig oder ist er noch? Ist noch, ne?
Ja, pass auf. Also genau, also er ist, er wurde jetzt vorerst jede weitere Tätigkeit für das BSI untersagt. Mit der Begründung, dass es einen irreparablen Schaden am öffentlichen Vertrauen gibt.
Das ist ja ungefähr so die, die, die keine Schuld zuweisende Begründung. Es gab offenbar in diesem Schreiben noch andere Punkte, die da angesprochen wurden,
dass es also mehrere interne Querelen zwischen BSI und BMI gegeben habe, dass es einmal eine Beschwerde gab, dass er einen toxischen Führungsstil habe und nicht quasi der, der Frauenförderung entgegen steht.
Diese Dinge liegen aber lange zurück und scheinen jetzt auch, also so wie ich das Lese behandelt worden zu sein. Entscheidend ist aber, in dieser Begründung seiner Untersagung, seinen Job auszuüben.
Ist überhaupt kein Bezug zu dieser Protelionssache oder auch den anderen Dingen, über die wir jetzt sprechen, die noch rausgekommen sind.
Also wir erinnern uns...
Arne Schimmung gründet einen Verein mit Hans Wilhelm Dünn, der so heißt wie eine Institution der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, nämlich Cyber-Sicherheitsrat.
Er gründet den ein Jahr nachdem es diese Institution gibt und das ist halt so ein Vernetzungsverein, der sich hier einen sehr offiziellen Anstrich gibt.
Das ganze Ding geht ziemlich außer Kurven und eigentlich jeder, der von außen darauf schaut, merkt, das ist irgendwie ein unsauberer Verein.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer wird Arne Schimmung, aber dann BSI-Präsident, tritt aus dem Verein aus und er hält aber offenbar noch freundschaftliche Verhältnisse auch zu.
Dem Herrn Dünn, mit dem er nicht nur diesen Verein gegründet hat, sondern auch früher ein Unternehmen zusammengeführt hat.
So viel zu der Vorgeschichte. Jetzt passiert ja das, dass nämlich das Unternehmen Infotex, das in den USA seit Längerem schon sanktioniert ist, weil es eben diese KGB-Ausgründung ist.
Und jetzt kommen die neuen Informationen, vor dem auch das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz seit 2019 warnt. Und zwar wohl nicht öffentlich, aber der Spiegel hat da mit einem Geschäftsführer eines Unternehmens gesprochen,
der offenbar beabsichtigt hatte, dieses Produkt zu kaufen oder es hatte und dann irgendwie vom Verfassungsschutz der Hinweis gekommen ist.
So übrigens, hier Verfassungsschutz, wir würden Ihnen empfehlen, das nicht zu verwenden. Es gibt in der öffentlichen Schilderung keine größeren Details drüber, aber kann man sich gut vorstellen,
es gibt im Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz die Abteilung für Spionageabwehr und sonstiges und wenn die natürlich gewisse Kenntnisse hat, dann kann die ja auch mal sich vertraulich an die Kundinnen des Unternehmens wenden.
So, das war quasi seit 2019 der Fall. Jetzt gibt es zwei Operationen und zwar eine des BND und eine des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz.
Die BND-Operation läuft seit mehreren Jahren und zielt auf den Infotex-Firmenkomplex ab.
Und diese Operation war offenbar so ertragreich oder erfolgreich, dass sie dreimal verlängert wurde, schreibt der Spiegel. Ich denke mir immer so, es kann sein, also wenn Überwachungsmaßnahmen verlängert werden, heißt es nicht notwendigerweise, dass sie erfolgreich waren.
Ja, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das erfolgreich war, ja, aber das war jetzt so. Wer die Überwachung verlängert, weil sie so erfolgreich war, das bin ich hier ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Aber in diesem Fall denke ich, ist es schon naheliegend.
Und diese Operation lief halt weiterhin mit anderen Worten dieses ganze Unternehmen in FOTEX, was sich ja dann in Prothelion umbenannt hat und eine BSI-Zertifizierung haben wollte,
ist seit Jahren eben offenbar im Blickwinkel des BNDs.
Außerdem hat das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz seit längerem den Vereinsvorsitzenden Cyber-Sicherheitsrats-Deutsch als EV Hans Wilhelm Dünn überwacht und eine weitere Person aus diesem Verein.
Das heißt, die waren mit ihrem Cyber-Sicherheitsrat, die Überwachungsziel des Verfassungsschutzes. Daher wurden teilweise Gespräche abgehört, unter anderem sogar mit einem Schönbom ab.
Also nicht einem Schönbom wurde abgehört, aber einem Schönbom hat eben mit diesem dünnen Telefoniert und weil der dünn abgehört wurde, wurde eben auch der Schönbom mit abgehört.
Also dieses Unternehmen Infotext, schrägstich, was sich ja dann umbenannt hat, in Prothelion, wurde vom Inlands- und Auslandsgeheimdienst der Bundesrepublik Deutschland seit Jahren überwacht.
Beziehungsweise das Unternehmen vom Auslandsgeheimdienst und der Cyber-Sicherheitsrat vom Inlandsgeheimdienst. So, jetzt kommt in Anfangszeichen das Problem.
Die haben den Schönbom nicht darüber informiert, weil der zu nah an dem Dünn dran ist. Das finde ich nachvollziehbar.
Ich meine, die haben seit über einem Jahrzehnt enge Kontakte und da kannst du natürlich nicht dem Schönbom sagen.
Übrigens hier dein Buddy, den überwachen wir gerade. Und wenn du da anrufst, hören wir auch deine Telefonate ab.
Also ist es verständlich, dass das wirklich ein Problem natürlich dann ist für die Geheimdienste und für das Innenministerium.
So, jetzt passiert folgendes. Dieses Unternehmen Prothelion ist ja einmal in den Cyber-Sicherheitsrat eingetreten, wo.
Wir eben sagen können, okay, danke.
Da wird sicherlich keine strenge Prüfung stattfinden. Wenn jemand sagt, ich werde dir für 5000 Euro im Jahr mitglied.
Und du musst irgendwie deine deine Firmenzentralen in den USA und Deutschland unterhalten und weiter rumrennen als Cyber Casper.
Da guckst du natürlich nicht genau hin, wer sich da bewirbt. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal klar.
Hinzu kommt aber, dass dieser Dünner offenbar doch ein bisschen sehr viel mehr Dreck am Stecken hatte. Wir haben es in der letzten Sendung behandelt und offenbar hat, dass das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz auch problematisch gesehen.
So, jetzt geht dieses Protelion nicht nur hin und tritt in die deutschen Cyber-Siehheitsrat ein, wo es mit Kusshand genommen wird, sondern bemüht sich für sein Produkt um eine BSI Zertifizierung.
So. Und.
Die dann was genau zertifizieren soll.
Naja, das ist, also du kannst ja alle möglichen Quatsch zertifizieren, hast du jetzt irgendwie so ein Produkt, ein Service oder sonst was. Dann gibt es vielleicht technische Richtlinien, dann gibt es irgendwelche Zertifizierungsvorgaben.
Und so eine Zertifizierung ist im Prinzip ja nur eine Formalie. Da gibt es klare Prüfkriterien, die du unter Beweis stellen musst oder die du dokumentieren musst, die vielleicht auch mal auditiert werden, stichprobenartig oder so.
Und dann wird es zertifiziert. Gibt es in allen möglichen Bereichen aus dem Spiegelartikel geht nicht genau hervor, was die zertifizieren wollten und in welchem Rahmen. Aber die wollten also irgendetwas, was sie haben, irgendetwas, was sie anbieten, wollten sie gerne vom BSI zertifiziert haben.
So, und diese Zertifizierung, nur um zu erklären, wie so eine Zertifizierung funktioniert, die hat natürlich klare Prüfvorgaben. Und die sind bekannt, da kann ja keine Willkür herrschen, dass das BSI sagt, dass eine Produkt zertifizieren wird, dass andere nicht.
Das heißt, die Prüfanforderungen sind benannt. Und entsprechend strebst du natürlich keine Zertifizierung an, wenn du dir nicht halbwegs sicher bist, dass du die formalen Kriterien erfüllst.
Normalerweise sollte das so sein.
Genau. Gleichzeitig hat dieses Protelion, die waren sich also auch so sicher, dass sie das sogar öffentlich bekannt gegeben haben, dass sie diese Zertifizierung anstreben. Ja, eben weil du, wenn du jetzt, also du kannst dir eigentlich schon sicher sein, wenn du nicht vollkommen mit einem Klammerbeäuern gepudert bist, dass du die Zertifizierung auch bestehst.
Das ist ja auch so, dass du das dann auch potenziell mit vielleicht ein paar Problemen, wo gesagt wird, dass und das müsste dann nochmal besser machen, dann kriegt er die oder so, ne. Aber da die Kriterien eben vorher bekannt sind, ist auch klar, dass du die, dass du die dann bestehst.
Und jetzt passiert folgendes. Das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz merkt also, okay, diese Protelion wollen sich jetzt irgendwie BSI Zertifizierung holen. Aber dem schön boom nicht, weil der den Kontakt zu dem Dünn hat und der Dünn irgendwie in jedem Überall seine Finger im Spiel hat und dann kriegt, lässt das BFV quasi über das BMI, den BSI einen Hinweis geben und wird gesagt, übrigens zertifiziert das man nicht.
Und daraufhin hat dann das BSI diese Zertifizierung verweigert. Aber du erkennst den Konflikt, der jetzt also offenbar in diesen Sicherheitsbehörden ist, dass sie dem BSI-Chefen dich vertrauen können mit den Informationen und ihren Aktivitäten.
Das ist ein bisschen unpraktisch.
Ist unpraktisch. Aber ich wurde da tatsächlich, was ist denn letzte Woche oder so,
war ich bei Kontraste im Interview, da wurde ich dazu gefragt, was ich denn dazu denke, dass die, naja, eine Zertifizierung öffentlich ankündigen und dann nicht bekommen.
Da ist es wirklich sehr naheliegend, dass dann geheimdienstliche Erkenntnisse dabei eine Rolle spielen, weil die kann eigentlich nur aus Formal,
also die kann nur abgelehnt werden, wenn, ähm, die könnte es dir, also vermutlich kannst du die sogar einklagen, da kommt jetzt wieder hier der Linus ist kein Jurist, ne, aber das ist halt schon ein objektives Verfahren, wo es Prüfkriterien gibt.
Naja, und da haben sie die eben, haben sie die Zertifizierung nicht bekommen.
Weißt du denn mit welcher Argumentation sie dir nicht bekommen haben?
Nein. Aber natürlich kann das... Also ich stelle mir diesen Prozess so vor.
Zuständige Mitarbeiter.
Dieses Unternehmen, nein, nein, nein, dieses Unternehmen wird die Zertifizierung angestrebt haben und dann wird die eben, hat das öffentlich auch noch angekündigt und dann wird das halt im Zweifelsfall, wird die eben verweigert.
Da wird es da irgendwie ungefähr so eine Begründung geben, wie der Schönbum, die jetzt bekommen hat.
Und dann wird Protelion sich potenziell überlegt haben können, so, naja, okay, wollen wir jetzt hier versuchen, verwaltungsrechtlich zu klagen oder sowas. Oder sagen wir es in Ordnung, die Zertifizierung ist eh egal.
Wir haben ja den Stempel vom Deutschen Zweifelsicherheitsrat. Also du brauchst ja auch diese Zertifizierung nicht unbedingt, du brauchst die Potenziell, um für bestimmte Einsatzbereiche geeignet zu sein.
Naja, das man eben sagt, okay.
Ja oder wenn Unternehmen halt die Anforderung haben, dass eine solche Zertifizierung vorliegen muss in ihren.
Dass dann was weiß ich in dieser kritischen Infrastruktur dürfen, nur das und das mit der und der Zertifizierung für den Betriebssohn so freigegeben oder so. Ja, also, aber es ist
oft, es ist also jetzt hier der bekannte Fall, dass die eine Zertifizierung angestrebt haben und dass es eine Intervention vom BMI gab, die denen nicht zu geben und dass das aber gleichzeitig
immer eine Information war, die mit der sie dem BSI nicht trauen konnten. Und das ist natürlich tatsächlich ein Problem. Also diesen, auch wenn der Schönbum weit weg von all diesen Protelionen ist,
hat er natürlich, ist es für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland ein Problem, wenn man den BSI-Chef nicht vertrauen kann, weil er irgendwie den Shady-Buddy hat da. Und genau, der BND war also
jetzt auch überhaupt nicht amüsiert, dass der Böhmermann mit dieser Sendung eben diese Protelion nur mal da halt überkocht, weil die offenbar eigentlich ganz happy waren, da weiter
potenzielle Forschung und Nachforschung anzustreben.
Jetzt sind sie natürlich alle gewarnt. Aber diese Meldung, dass da diese Verbindung als Fischigelten, die gab es ja auch schon 2019, wie wir in den Kommentaren hingewiesen wurden. Da war schon mal was bei der Tagesschau.
Das haben wir in der letzten Sendung ausführlich dargestellt, dass das 2019 losging mit dem Dünnen. Ja, also weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, welchen Kommentar du dich beziehst, aber das alles mit diesem Dünnen schon öffentlich äußerst kritikwürdig war,
ist 2019 gewesen, das war dieses Interview, ich glaube mit Panorama und ich würde jetzt auch das eine Leyenvermutung, aber sag ich mal, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Bestrebungen des BFV da begonnen haben.
Die lesen ja sehr viel Zeitung, wenn sie nicht telefonate abhören. Aber also spannender Sachverhalt, weil es natürlich offenbar in diesem Fall tatsächlich ein Problem ist,
dass das mit BMI nicht dem BSI-Präsidenten vertrauen kann in solchen Angelegenheiten, wenn der da einen windigen Kumpel hat mit allerlei skurrieren Geschäftsbeziehungen.
Aber nochmal ist jetzt also...
Das können Sie ja auch wieder nicht vorwerfen. Dass Sie in einem spezifischen Verfahren der Spionageabwehr nicht vertrauen konnten, wird man da mal sehen.
Jetzt wird sich natürlich die andere Frage stellen, wer weiß, was Inhalt der Telefonate war. Aber Tatsache ist, dass der Schönbom eben sehr, sehr enge Kontakte zu dem Dünnen hat.
Die haben, sagen wir, entscheidende Familienereignisse miteinander begangen und wie gesagt, hatten früher eine Firma zusammen und so weiter.
Das heißt das Ganze und jetzt finde ich es ja spannende. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob der Bömermann das wusste oder die Redaktion Bömermann wusste,
dass sie da jetzt in so ein Westmest einer laufenden Geheimdienstoperation reinsticht.
Und jetzt wird es natürlich echt spannend. Ich denke, die Sache hier ist, dass die Erfassung, dass öffentliche Vertrauen ist für immer verloren.
Dass die schon zutreffend ist.
Gleichzeitig gibt es jetzt einen Disziplinarverfahren gegen Herrn Schönbom, welches er wiederum selber angestrengt hat.
Also der hat gesagt, ich verlange ein Disziplinarverfahren, dass die Vorwürfe gegen mich untersucht, die ich übrigens gerne mal hören würde.
Und kann nicht, also ist natürlich ein einleuchtender Weg, wenn er seinen Ruf hier korrigieren möchte oder bereidigen möchte von potenziell falschen Vorwürfen.
Also er wurde ja mittlerweile von seinem Amt abberufen auch.
Das ist nicht der Fall. Dem wurde die Ausübung seines Amtes untersagt.
Stätten wir Wikipedia, am 18. Oktober 22 wurde er von seinem Amt abberufen.
Nee, der wurde die Ausführung seines Amtes untersagt. Das ist ein Unterschied in meiner Wahrnehmung. Den kannst du ja nicht. Also, ja, natürlich wird dem das jetzt nicht wieder erlaubt werden.
Aber offiziell ist er Präsident des Bundesamtes für Verfassungssch... Sorry, des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik, der das gerade nicht machen darf.
Und der nächste Schritt wird natürlich sein, dass irgendjemand anderes dahin gesetzt wird. Aber aktuell...
Er ist abberufen.
Tim.
Tagesschau. Fäser Beruf BSI Chef. Schön Boden ab.
Ja, und was steht da? Was steht da drunter?
Dass er abrufen wurde. Wer seine Nachfolge antreten soll, steht laut noch nicht fest.
Ja, das sagte ich doch, Junge, ihm wurde gerade die Ausführung seines Amtes untersagt. Der ist weiterhin bei vollen Bezügen und es wird selbstverständlich ein Nachfolger kommen.
Okay, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher was abberufen.
Ja, dann...
Richtig faktisch heiß, aber das fand statt.
Ja, wie ich mehrmals sagte zu Beginn der Sendung zu Beginn dieses gesamten Themas, ihm ist die Ausübung seiner Rolle untersagt worden.
Er hat er aber nach meiner Auffassung ist er hat er weiter hin. Also ich meine, der hat die Bezüge, der hat diesen Job teilt, aber er darf ihn gerade nicht ausführen.
Und das wird natürlich wird er dann irgendwann eine Entlassungsurkunde aus diesem Job bekommen oder einen anderen.
Ja, aber nach meinem Verständnis ist ihm gerade die Ausübung dieser Tätigkeit untersagt, was selbstverständlich bedeutet, dass er, dass, dass, dass das auch nicht wieder der Fall werden wird.
Aber es gibt keinen Nachfolger und es gibt niemand anders, der diese Rolle trägt und entsprechend ja warten wir da jetzt, warten wir jetzt auf die Dinge.
Ich gehe aber eben davon aus, er versucht sicher offensichtlich mit diesem Disziplinarverfahren dagegen zu wehren bzw. damit dem Beweis zu erbringen, dass es keinen Anlass gibt, ihm.
Die Ausübung seines Amtes zu verwehren.
Dem gegenüber sagt das BMI irreparable beschädigtes Vertrauensverhältnis sowohl öffentlich als auch durch die Vorgänge, die uns hier bekannt sind intern.
Und ich sehe jetzt, also natürlich wird der nicht wieder BSI Präsident werden. Das halte ich für uns das unwahrscheinlich.
Ja, denke ich auch.
Aber wenn jetzt hier, wir können mal BSI-Bund.de, das ist eigentlich ganz interessant, mal schauen. Wenn man mal schaut, wo kann man das BSI, Organisation und Aufbau, Leitung, der Präsident,
Arne Schönbohm steht jetzt gerade wunderbar auf der Seite des BSI, der Vizepräsident Gerd Scharphüser und ich denke der Scharphüser wird den Laden jetzt gerade führen.
Insofern, wenn er wirklich abberufen wäre, dann würde ich davon ausgehen, dass er nicht mehr auf dieser Webseite stünde.
Oder der Webmaster ist im Urlaub, das kann natürlich auch sein.
Oder der Antrag an den Webmaster die Seite.
Wurde per Diebmehl für...
Zu ändern befindet sich noch in einem Post wie ich.
Also, de facto ist er einfach weg, abberufen, freigestellt, was auch immer. Er übt diese Position jetzt nicht aus, auch wenn es sozusagen keinen Nachfrage gibt, den man stellt, dass er auf die Webseite draufschreiben kann.
Egal, wir streiten uns um Worte, wollten nur nichts Falsches sagen, aber so ist die offizielle Darstellung.
Der Mann kämpft jetzt wahrscheinlich um die Rettung seines Rufes. Auf jeden Fall eine sehr spannende Geschichte und es wird sich natürlich, denke ich, relativ
schnell zeigen, ob er da wirklich Teil der Verschwörung ist oder mit dem Dünder unter einer Decke steht und gegen die Bundesrepublik Deutschland gearbeitet hat.
So ungefähr, das hielt ich dann doch für einen riesigen Skandal, wenn der noch käme.
Jut, dann wollte ich mal die Gelegenheit nutzen auf ein kleines Softwareprojektchen hinzuweisen, was meine Kolleginnen und ich in den letzten Wochen und Monaten gebastelt haben.
Und zwar haben wir ja hier auch in letztens ein bisschen über die Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesprochen und die Identifier, die dort gespeichert werden sollen.
Und in der ursprünglichen Ausgestaltung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung war davon auch die E-Mai betroffen, die IMEI, der International Mobile Equipment Identifier.
Also nicht nur habt ihr eine IMSI, International Mobile Subscriber Identity, was im Prinzip das ist, was ihr durch eure SIM-Karte auch bei alten Telefonen noch in der Hand halten
könnt, sondern auch eine international standardisierte Seriennummer könnte man sagen, eures Entgerät ist.
Und wenn man sich jetzt an so ein Mobilfunknetz anmeldet, dann wird in dem Rahmen auch die IMEI übertragen.
Und jetzt hält sicher unter vielen Leuten die Vorstellung, dass man durch das Verwenden einer neuen SIM-Karte eine neue Identität finden könnte.
Also hast du ein Handy, hast jetzt die eine SIM-Karte drin, kaufst du jetzt was, was ich eine andere auf dem Flohmarkt oder irgendwo wo man noch vielleicht ohne namentliche Registrierung eine kriegt und dann könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen, man wäre nun mit einer neuen Identität unterwegs.
Das ist aber nicht der Fall, weil eben diese IMEI des Telefones auch mit erfasst wird und Teil der Kommunikation ist.
Wir haben da so ein Gerät bekommen bzw. ich habe das zu Weihnachten bekommen vor einiger Zeit. Das ist ein Mi-Fi, ein sogenanntes, also ein kleiner, so ein, sieht aus wie ein überdimensionales Handy.
Hat relativ viel Akku und steckt meine SIM-Karte rein und dann macht das einen WLAN auf.
Und dieses Teil hat die besondere Eigenschaft, dass man sehr einfach das einschalten kann, dass es allen Traffic durch Tor routet oder wahlweise auch durch einen VPN oder man kann es auch ausschalten.
Dann hast du also ein kleines Gerät, was sich mit dem Mobilfunknetz verbindet und dann direkt allen Traffic zum Beispiel durch Tor routet und dann bist du quasi anonym mehr unterwegs.
Aber du bist natürlich immer noch den ganzen Erfassungen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung ausgesetzt. Das Problem lässt sich potenziell lösen, indem man sich irgendeine andere Anonyme SIM-Karte holt, aber dann hat man immer noch das Problem der IMEi.
Und das ist mitunter gar nicht so klein das Problem, denn zum Beispiel auf der Rechnung meines iPhones steht die IMEi drauf. Das heißt, mein iPhone ist quasi kann nachweisbar zumindest an meine Kreditkarte
und meine Rechnung von Apple verbunden werden.
Also hatten wir dieses Gerät und haben uns noch mal ein bisschen so angeschaut und macht ja erst mal ganz netten Eindruck, irgendwie anonym im Internet sein und so.
Und dann haben wir eben festgestellt bei näherer Untersuchung, dass das Teil so ein paar Sachen speichert, die ein anonymitätversprechendes Gerät nicht speichern sollte.
Und das es ein Basement hat, wo man mit einem einfachen AT-Kommando tatsächlich die IMEi ändern kann.
Und haben dann ein kleines Software Paket gebaut, wo man also einen IMEI Wechsel einleiten kann. Im Display bitte auch die SIM-Karte wechseln, weil sonst macht das Ganze natürlich keinen Sinn,
weil dann kontaminiert wieder deine neue SIM-Karte mit der alten IMEI.
Außerdem löscht das Ding alle Logs, weil das Teil irgendwie Mac-Adressen speichert und so und link die nach Defnull und dann werden noch die Mac-Adresse für WLAN bzw. die BSS-ID auch bei jedem Start.
Randomisiert und ja war so ein kleines Nebenprojekt was wir so gemacht haben und damit hat man jetzt also kann man ein Gerät haben was mit dem man tatsächlich wenn man denn in der Lage wäre eine
anonyme SIM-Karte irgendwo zu bekommen tatsächlich vollständig anonym unter zufälliger IMII durch Tor sich mit Internet verbinden kann und wenn hier dieser Vorratsdaten Speicherungsquatsch
weitergeht ist das vielleicht für einige Leute interessant ist es aber vor allem auch interessant vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt in Deutschland wo man jetzt nicht so große Probleme hat wie zum
Beispiel die demokratische Bewegung im Iran Menschen in China oder auch in Russland wo es ja sehr schwierig ist erstens ein unzensierten und zweitens ein überwachungsfreien Zugang zum Netz zu finden
habe auch gehört dass das wechsel der IMII in der Türkei relativ beliebt ist weil da auch eine stärkere Überwachung herrscht naja naher ein kleines Paket ein kleines Software Paket für.
Open WIT raus gemacht und freuen uns wenn Leute da das weiterentwickeln weil wir glauben dass noch sehr viele andere Basebands das auch unterstützen und kann man sich auf GitHub anschauen.
Kurze Nachfrage. Ich gebe mir eine neue IMEI, aus welchem Numberspace holt man die sich dann? Ich habe einen Gerät zugeordnet, wenn ich mir eine andere nehme, dann kann ich für ein anderes Gerät gehalten werden, was im selben Netz eingebucht sein kann.
Ja super super Frage denn ich wollte noch unser White Paper dazu empfehlen wir haben nämlich dazu so ich glaube 14 15 Seiten Report geschrieben wobei das alles mal genau durchgehen also quasi eine kleine Studie in wie Mobilfunknetze überwachen könnten. Also ja die IMEI ist tatsächlich.
Warte mal wie viel davon sind das also die ersten zwei sind der Reporting Buddy Identifier also der Hersteller dann kommt der Type Identifier der im Prinzip map auf sagen wir mal eine Art Gerät dann hast du. Sechs die im Prinzip der Seriennummer entsprechen und am Ende eine Prüf Summe.
Und du kannst jetzt, wenn du sagst du würfelst dir IMEIs oder du machst die anders, könntest es jetzt theoretisch vollständig random machen, musst aber natürlich noch gucken, dass diese die Prüfzumme am Ende passt.
Du kannst aber natürlich auch, und das haben wir gemacht, wir haben einfach überlegt, okay, welche Tax, also welche Type Allocation Codes, also die zwei für den Reporting Buddy und dann die sechs für den Type, dann nehmen wir einfach die von üblichen Telefoten,
also aktuell häufig verbreiteten Telefonen, machen dann den Serienteil, also diese sechs Ziffern, die randomisieren wir einfach und hauen am Ende ein Checkdigit rein.
So, jetzt hast du genau den richtigen Punkt. Es könnte sein, dass du jetzt im Zweifelsfalle zufällig eine IMEI imitierst, die oder eine IMEI setzt, die ein anderes Telefon im gleichen Netz auch hat.
Da die aber keinerlei Routing-Relevanz hat, ist es eigentlich egal. Also wird es jetzt, also es ist nicht wie eine MAC-Adresse in einem Ethernet oder einem
Wi-Fi-Netzwerk, wo das tatsächlich eine Hardware-Adresse ist, die eine Rolle spielt für Routing,
sondern das ist im Prinzip einfach nur so ein Datum, was de facto egal ist.
Na, würde es jetzt eine invalide IMEI, wo die Prüfzumme nicht stimmt, mit senden, das wäre alles egal.
Also das hat keinen Einfluss auf die Funktionalität des Mobilfunknetzes oder den Service eines anderen bekommen, weil der Identifier da eben ein anderer ist. Also da ist es dann eigentlich die Timsy, eine aus der Imsy abgeleitet Temporary, Mobile Subscriber, Identifier und das für das Routing oder Funktionalität dürfte das keine Probleme machen.
Und theoretisch könntest du auch in einigen Ländern, kann man E-Mails sperren, das ist der Versuch, wenn dein Telefon gestohlen wurde, dass du dann sagst, hier pass auf die und die E-Mail, die ich möchte, dass dieses Telefon in allen Netzen gesperrt wird. Eigentlich eine sehr wirkungsvolle, eine sehr sinnvolle Maßnahme, um den Diebstahl von Mobiltelefonen einzuschränken.
Genau deswegen wird sie so gut wie niemandem umgesetzt.
Ja
Genau.
Die ersten beiden Ziffern sind nicht der Hersteller, sondern es ist ein welches Land, das für die Vergabe zuständig ist.
Das ist der Hersteller in diesem zweiten Teil mit drin.
Ah, okay, sorry, du hast recht. Ja, ja, der, ich war nämlich gerade auch verwundert, dass die...
Mehr als 99.
Also ist dann quasi der zuteilende, die die, die, die, die IMEI zuteilende Stelle und die sechs dahinter sind. Identifizieren den Brand Owner und das Device Model.
Ja, genau. Also, dass... So was machen wir, wenn uns auf der Arbeit langweilig ist und ich freue mich auf Prorequest. Weil, ja genau, hier.
Wir haben nämlich dann noch eine Sache offen gelassen und zwar je nachdem, was für eine IMEI du nachmars, hat das Gerät ja auch ein,
kann das imitierte Gerät ja auch bestimmte Frequenzen funken und andere nicht und da ist jedes da ist jede Jagd anders und theoretisch haben wir jetzt noch einen Aspekt, dass quasi wir eine IMEI von einem Telefon
Modell fälschen könnten, dann auf einer Frequenzfunktion, die dieses Telefon aber eigentlich nicht unterstützt und könnten damit so quasi einen,
Hinweis geben, dass hier etwas nicht stimmt und ich habe damals auf GitHub ein Issue angelegt mit welchem Kommando man auch das fixen könnte.
Wir haben es nicht gemacht, weil das eben potentiell die Servicequalität beeinflussen könnte, wenn du auf einmal eben auf weniger Frequenzen funkst als dein Basement unterstützt und deswegen haben wir das nicht implementiert.
Wahrscheinlich für wenige Menschen jetzt von Nutzen, aber eine ganz interessante oder für wenige Menschen in Deutschland von Nutzen, aber wir fanden es als Studie ein bisschen interessant, uns da auch mal mit dem Tracking usw. auseinanderzusetzen und
manchmal braucht man ja auch so Fingerübungen.
Gut, kommen wir zur europäischen Politik. Wir werden jetzt zu den USA und wir werden uns die Frage der europäischen Politik über die EU nachdenken.
Ja, wir hatten ja Kali's die gerade erst in der Sendung. Jetzt wurde die Kampagne gelaunched, die internationale Stop-Scanning-Me, wo sich 118 Organisationen angeschlossen
haben und die jetzt also ein Ende dieses Vorstoßes fordern und zum Beispiel sich dann auch die Mühe machen, die Äußerungen von Ilva Johansson zu korrigieren, wenn sie da halt mit unterwirklich
wilde Thesen von sich gibt. Und zwar hat sie bei der Vorstellung oder bei so einer Fragerunde.
Ja, also eine Anhörung im Liebausschuss, wo sie dann eben Fragen beantworten sollte, hat sie ja so, ja, die relevanten Fragen nicht beantwortet und was richtig geil war. Da musste
ich auch fragen, also ist das Inkompetenz oder wirklich boshaft Lüge, sagt sie, ja.
Guck mal hier, wenn ich bei WhatsApp, wenn ich da eine URL eingebe.
Artikel oder so, dann erscheint sofort dann irgendwie das Artikelbild da. Also scannen die das.
Und es stimmt natürlich nicht, das wird ja also dein WhatsApp lädt sich lokal, greift auf diese Seite zu gucken ob da irgendwelche Preview-Images sind und rendert dir die schon mal ein.
Und die auf der Empfängerseite passiert das gleiche. Das ist ja nicht zu vergleichen mit einem Scan auf die Inhalte eine Check Summe darüber zu bilden und potenziell mit einer AI zu entscheiden ob das jetzt Kinderpornografie ist oder nicht.
Ja, es ist ja wirklich, also so was von einem Harnherr beigezogen, ein komplett verrückter Vergleich,
dass ich mich wirklich frage, es ist eigentlich unvorstellbar,
dass jemand als EU-Kommissare mit einem solchen Gesetzesvorstoß bringt und so wenig Motivation hat die technischen Hintergründe zu verstehen.
Ja, das kann ich mir eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen. Andererseits fände ich es auf irre,
wenn eine Person als EU-Kommissare einen derartigen Gesetzesvorstoß voranbringt und absichtlich so ein Scheiß erzählt.
Also egal wie man das erklärt, er kann ja überhaupt nicht sein. Also es finde ich wirklich irre.
Das ist eine gefühlte Vorstellung davon, wie es funktioniert, offenbar.
Das ist der erste Schritt im Internet.
Sie hat auch ein Handy.
Das sieht man ja. Das ist ja da zu sehen. Alles ganz klar.
Ja, da gibt es also eine Pressemitteilung, auch wieder vom Chaos Computer Club, die hat Kalisigos teils formuliert, in der sie auch nochmal sich die Mühe gemacht hat,
halt diesen, ja, den ganzen Quatsch zu widerlegen und ein Positionspapier eben auch von den europäische Digital Rights, das Safe Internet für alle, abholt, private und secure Communications,
ja, das ist irgendwie 50 Seiten oder so, in denen dieser ganze Unsinn, der da von deren Seite behauptet werden muss, erst mal wieder auf die Füße gestellt werden muss, ja, 52
Seiten, wo erklärt werden muss, warum das alles Unsinn ist, ne, und du hast auf der anderen Seite irgendwie so eine Kommissar, die sagt, hier, guck, WhatsApp, also das ist natürlich schon wirklich
belastend, möchte ich sagen, aber darüber haben wir ja auch schon gesprochen, insofern die Kampagne ist da, es gibt dieses, ein schönes Video von Alexander Lehmann, was wir verlinkt haben und jetzt, wie
wir auch schon sagten, jetzt ist natürlich notwendig, dass dieser Widerstand auch nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern eben auch international sich formiert, um hier das Schlimmste zu verhindern.
Ja, also teilt, teilt mit eurer Freunde und sagt die...
Sag all Bescheid. So, jetzt kann man zu deinen Vorhersagen. So, jetzt kann man zu deinen Vorhersagen.
Ich habe ja vorher gesagt, dass der Salat gewinnt.
Ja, aber jetzt haben wir erst so richtig den Salat, weil es jetzt doch ja danach aussieht, dass Elon Musk Twitter kaufen muss.
Ja, das also, ich, genau, ich, mir ist wirklich nicht ganz klar, ob ich das hier in der Sendung behandelt habe oder nicht. Also er hat kurz vor, zu Stande kommen, des Gerichtsverfahrens, in dem er versucht hätte, auszuhandeln, dass er Twitter nicht kaufen muss.
Sehr kurz davor gesagt, okay, hier, ich bin bereit, den Kauf zu den Konditionen und dem Angebot, was ich ursprünglich gemacht habe, auch tatsächlich zum Abschluss zu bringen.
Twitter hat dann ja zunächst daran gezweifelt und gesagt, okay, lass uns mal weitermachen, aber wir halten hier mal die Bemühungen, dich darauf zu verklagen, erst mal noch aktiv.
Inzwischen sind hier aber weitere Schritte gegangen und es finden offenbar Verhandlungen mit zwischen den Repräsentanten von Elon Musk und Twitter statt. Und aktuell sieht es danach aus, dass er tatsächlich diesen Kauf, ich würde sagen, wieder will ich durchziehen muss.
Ja also werden das ja mal kurz angesprochen dass die ganze Sache halt jetzt in Delaware quasi vor Gericht liegt und die Wahrscheinlichkeit. Dass er dort das noch weggebogen bekommt die war halt gering erst mal weil der Fall eigentlich Börsen rechtlich wo relativ klar ist er hat das halt einfach unterschrieben hat gesagt ich kauf das und damit ist das Ding einfach rechts gültig.
Und dann kann man ja mit allen möglichen ausreden und darum ging es jetzt im Prinzip und Delaware ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade so bekannt als Rechtsstand Ort.
Für Leute die sich sozusagen vor großen Unternehmen.
Aus der Verantwortung stehlen wollen mit anderen Worten das hat sich offenbar abgezeichnet dass er dort nur im Zweifel noch mehr zahlen muss strafen und was nicht alles. Und ist im Prinzip der Entscheidung zuvor gekommen so deute ich das.
Ja, ich also genau das muss da passiert sein. Irgendjemand muss ihm gesagt haben, Junge, du machst dich zum Vollaffen und potentiell natürlich auch. Also der hat natürlich jetzt das Problem bleibt.
Twitter wird jetzt an jemanden verkauft, der sich die letzten Monate mühe gegeben hat, kein gutes Haar an dem Unternehmen zu lassen.
Und also ich kann mir auf jeden Fall nicht vorstellen, dass der gerade zu Hause sitzt und sagt, ey, voll geil, ich kauf Twitter, ist super gelaufen für mich.
Ja, auch da.
Ja, er wird irgendwie, ich meine, es ist einfach nahezu unmöglich in seinen Kopf reinzuschauen. Der Typ hat halt schon eine, ich sag mal, eine praktische
Intelligenz am Start, die es ihm ermöglicht, all diese ganzen Projekte voranzutreiben, die er nun vorangetrieben hat und da waren ja kaum Ausfälle dabei.
Und trotzdem ist er natürlich auch durch diese Rolle in zunehmendem Maße zu so einer politischen, oder sozusagen mal zu so einer gesellschaftspolitischen
Größe und damit auch zu so einem Problem geworden, weil okay, solange er jetzt irgendwie tolle Sachen macht, dann ist das so das eine. Aber in dem Moment, wo
diese Machtagglomeration, die zwangsläufig damit verbunden ist, dann auch irgendwann in eine falsche Richtung schießt, dann wird es natürlich schnell problematisch. Und er ist schwer einzunorden, aber er ist irgendwie jetzt,
ist jetzt nicht so der totale, super rechtslastige, mega-Republikaner.
Ja, das ist er nicht. Trotzdem steht er dieser ganzen Welt irgendwie auch nahe.
Der hat nur mal so kurze... Also Kanye West dieser...
Ja, ich glaube der ist ja auch diagnostiziert.
Wenn nicht, wird es Zeit.
Ja, der hat... das ist ein manischer Irrer, ja? Der hat dann irgendwie...
Kanye West hat gesagt, er möchte Pala kaufen.
Diese rechtsradikale...
Wo die ganzen Nazis in den USA sich versammeln. Donald Trump hat ja seinen Truth.Social läuft, ob ich auch nicht besonders gut, aber hat er.
Und Elon Musk hat einen Tweet abgesendet und dann aber gelöscht, indem er quasi die drei Musketiere darstellt. Also auf diese drei Musketiere mit Trump, Musk und Kanye West, die drei Köpfe drauf gemacht hat.
Mit dem Kommentar in retrospect, it was inevitable. Also in der Rückbetrachtung war es unvermeidbar und stellt sich da auf eine Ebene mit Kanye West und Donald Trump.
Mit Truth, Social, Parler und X. Und er hat ja diese Ankündigung gemacht, X wäre, also sein Ziel wäre, X die Everything App zu machen.
Everything App ist ein Prinzip, also es könnte ja tatsächlich seine Bestrebung sein. So etwas wie WeChat und AliPay oder AliChat oder wie das.
WeChat ist in China, ich kann den Markt enttäuschend nicht sagen, aber die haben irgendwie so was. Wenn Menschen was im Internet machen, ist es sehr wahrscheinlich, dass sie es mit WeChat machen.
Weil es eben genau und dass er quasi Bestrebungen haben könnte, Twitter in so etwas umzubauen. Und im Prinzip vielleicht der Wert, den er in Twitter sieht, weniger vielleicht die existierende Plattform ist als die Nutzerinnenbasis.
Das ist also ein großer Markenname ist, die man dann und eine große Nutzungsbasis, die man dann umbauen kann oder weiterentwickeln kann. Aber da wären wir auch wahrscheinlich vielleicht andere Unternehmen eingefallen, wo man mehr Nutzer kaufen kann.
Aber ich habe ja wirklich einen Herz für Internetrolle.
Aber ich kann mir wirklich nicht vorstellen, dass man sich, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, in welchem halbwegs vernünftigen Hirn es für eine, man es lustig findet, sich selber auf einen, mit Kanye West und Donald Trump auf einen Niveau zu stellen. Vielleicht war er einfach wieder in irgendeinem Rauschzustand, er hat jetzt ja offenbar auch gelöscht am Ende.
Es gibt ja diesen schönen Begriff von Crème de la Nologie, also die Kunst herauszulesen, was denn der Creme wohl vorhat, weil er sich ja dann immer so gut abschirmt. So, ich glaube wir brauchen hier das Feld der Muscology, um einfach mal rauszufinden, wohin der Typ eigentlich will.
Weil es ist einfach auch gerade jetzt im Konflikt mit der Ukraine, ist sein Verhalten halt auch total erratisch. Also auf der einen Seite twittert er gerade zu die Putin-Propaganda heraus, schlägt irgendwie der Ukraine vor, hier die Creme abzutreten, weil der noch nie richtig Teil der Ukraine gewesen, was auch historisch vorkommt, falsch ist.
Also wird die auch mit falschen Belegen dort argumentiert, dann leistet er sich irgendwelche Twitter-Gefächte mit Vedev und so was. Also das ist einfach, das ist glaube ich so ein bisschen das Problem von so Leuten, die...
Einen Knall haben.
Ja, die sagen wir mal, ich meine, stell dir mal vor, du wirst jetzt sozusagen Chef, Gründerbetreiber wie auch immer von so einer der drei erfolgreichsten, also von drei der
erfolgreichsten Unternehmen der letzten Zeit, die alle irgendwie in ihrem Bereich die Maßstäbe neu definiert haben. So, und das gilt für seine Unternehmen. Es gilt für Tesla, es gilt für
SpaceX, geilt auch schon vorher für PayPal. So, und dann hast du da irgendwie was weiß ich,
wie viele Millionen Follower auf Twitter und jeder Pups, den du in diese Welt lässt, wird sozusagen instantan innerhalb von Mikrosekunden irgendwie weltweit debattiert. Das ist nicht einfach da,
irgendwie alle seine Sinne noch beisammen zu halten. Das gilt für...
Ja, deswegen sucht man sich ja dann potenzielle Hilfe.
Ja, das könnte man zum Beispiel bei tun. Aber du kannst dich auch nachvollziehen, dass manche dann irgendwie auch ein bisschen dran scheitern.
Also irgendeinen Modus musst du natürlich dazu finden. Da hast du so ein bisschen diesen Aldi-Modus.
Ja, frag mal in Deutschland, wer irgendwie Aldi gehört, wer diese Personen sind, wird dir keiner beantworten können.
Also die reichsten Leute in Deutschland.
Die Brüder Albrecht.
Ja, die Gebrüder einbrechen so. Und jetzt Lidl irgendwie also. Geben wir die größten Unternehmer und die reichsten Personen Deutschland durch. Ok, so Quant und so weiter.
Kennt man noch so ein bisschen, aber die allermeisten davon geben aber auch nicht auch nur ein Mux in dieser Öffentlichkeit ab.
Ja.
Sie hat sich schön bedeckt, bloß, nicht groß, irgendwie rumprallen, irgendwie so. Und das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht die American Way.
Und Mass dreht das irgendwie alles nach innen und geht einfach so dermaßen ins Extrem, dass man einfach überhaupt nicht mehr weiß, woran man ist.
Das mag auch ein bisschen Teil seiner Strategie zu sein. Wie du schon sagst, ist irgendwie auch wirklich auch ein Deluxe-Troll. Und hat offensichtlich auch so einfach seinen Spaß.
Aber inwiefern sozusagen auch einer gewissen Verantwortung, die man in so eine Rolle hat, gerecht wird. Da muss ich dir sehr starke Zweifel anmelden.
Warum hat der Masse denn nicht Aldi gekauft?
Schlag ihm das mal auf Twitter vor.
Kauft doch all die!
Passiert! Ich habe mich redet, aber ich werde nicht auf deinem.
Kannst du überall deine Autos verkaufen? Ich war noch nicht hier, ich war noch nicht da.
Naja super. Tesla jetzt bei Altinot.
Tesla 3 Model Nord und Model Süd.
Uhhh.
Ja also ich muss sagen, oder... also... Da sind wir!
Die eigentliche Frage, die eigentliche Frage, ich meine es geht ja jetzt vor allem, also gut, Twitter kommt jetzt mit ins Spiel und die andere Technologie ist halt Starlink.
Warum erwähne ich jetzt diese beiden? Weil ich die beide eben für kritische Infrastrukturen halte mittlerweile.
Klar, Twitter mag nicht das größte Netzwerk sein, aber wir wissen alle, dass es so der Ort, wo der ganze politische Battle weltweit stattfindet, ist einfach so.
Du sagst was auf Twitter, dann hat das irgendwie relevant, du sagst was auf Facebook interessiert mittlerweile keine Sau mehr.
Weil das einfach auch durch die Plattformen selber, durch die Wahl der Plattformen selber natürlich auch mitbestimmt wird, was es für eine Deutungshoheit hat.
Spätestens seit Trump ist das halt so. Und mit Starlink ist es wiederum so, dass, es gibt ja jetzt Berichte, dass die Regierung in den USA sich Gedanken darüber macht, inwiefern halt Musk mit seinen Aktivitäten jetzt auch reguliert gehört.
Weil natürlich Starlink so eine Irre Macht hat, das ist halt einfach ein kaum, also es gibt natürlich auch andere Projekte, die versuchen Ähnliches zu machen, aber im Punkt Ausbau und wie gut es tatsächlich real funktioniert, kommt da halt nichts mit.
So ein des Atoliten Internet Infrastruktur ist natürlich wirklich ein Machtfaktor, insbesondere jetzt gerade, nicht nur dort, aber insbesondere jetzt gerade im Krieg in der Ukraine.
Würde jetzt Musk irgendwie morgen komplett abdrehen und zum Putin versteher vollständig werden und so weiter, dann könnte man sich natürlich schon fragen, oh Gott, wo geht die Reise hin und genauso.
Es ist natürlich der Gedanke, dass jetzt Twitter in irgendeiner Form in Richtung Parler oder through social abdreht oder auch nur Trump dort wieder ein Account macht, auch schon scary enough.
Es ist einfach alles irre.
Ja, die USA, die USA machen sich jetzt mal langsam Gedanken darüber und sagen Moment mal, wir sind mit unserer Raumfahrt inzwischen signifikant von SpaceX abhängig.
Der bringt das Internet in irgendwelche Länder, wo er will oder nicht. Und da gibt es ja auch irgendwelche von mir nicht näher nach vollzogenen, komischen Dinge.
Ob er das da jetzt bereitstellt oder ob er da vielleicht doch mit Putin drüber spricht, dass das in richtigen Fällen ausschaltet.
Immerhin haben jetzt auch mal die meisten verstanden, dass Starlink in der Ukraine bereitzustellen, eher eine Militärhilfe ist, als dass da noch jemand twittern kann.
Und wenn der jetzt auch noch ein reichweiten starkes Massen-Medium gehört, dass man sich echt mal überlegen muss. Also ich sag mal, in anderen Ländern hätte der schon längst einen sehr unglücklichen Norwich-Schock-Vorfall gehabt oder so.
Weil man sich so etwas lieber nicht leisten möchte.
Mal schnell mal aus dem Fenster oder hat ein Herzanfall.
Ja, bedauerlicher Fall von Suizid. Und zumindest kann ich mir vorstellen, dass jemand, der sich in den USA,
vielleicht geostrategische Gedanken macht, wenn davon ausgeht, dass der Land in zehn Jahren noch gibt oder zum Ziel hat, dass er in zehn Jahren noch geben soll.
Er sich auch darüber Gedanken macht, wie man diesen Mask unter Kontrolle bekommt, der ja, sag ich mal, das Madman-Doctrini-Tag auf Twitter lebt.
Ja, also da erwarte ich auch tatsächlich Maßnahmen. Also das wird sicherlich nicht komplett auflagenfrei ablaufen. Die USA ist jetzt da nicht so doof wie Deutschland und kriegt das irgendwie alles nicht so richtig mit. Ich meine, unser Bundeskanzler will jetzt hier irgendwie auch,
die Chinesen in Hamburger Hafen,
reinlassen, obwohl alle schon sagen, sag mal hast du so noch alle?
Uns ist gerade hier irgendwie die Pipeline explodiert und jetzt wieder so ein Nummer.
Jetzt wollen die in der Hafen gehen.
Da reagiert das amerikanische Establishment dann doch etwas nervöser drauf. Und die haben dann im Zweifelsfall auch Möglichkeiten irgendwo aufzutauchen und mal sehr klar zum Ausdruck zu bringen, was sie davon halten.
Wir beobachten das weiter und sind ein bisschen ratlos.
Kennst du diese, es gibt im Internet eine Liste, die Menschen, die von ihrer eigenen Erfindung getötet wurden?
Ich mag euch.
Dass der Segway Investor irgendwie mit dem Segway von der Klippe gefahren ist.
Er kann hohen.
Mal gucken wie das so mit diesen Self-Driving-Testers weitergeht.
Vielleicht fällt die mir an Starlings, hat sie die Doppelkoppe.
Oder der riecht sich bei Twitter zu lange auf. Ich will auch nicht wissen, wie viele Leute Twitter jedes Jahr offen gewissen hat, die da irgendwie mit einer Herz-Attacke Koffee-Fe sich aus dem Flame-Worfer abschienen.
Clearview AI, letzte Nachricht am heutigen Tage. Clearview AI kennen wir, das ist das Unternehmen, das maßenhaft Fotos in social media sammelt.
Und daraus dann eine Biometrie-Erkennungsplattform baut, die von Strafverfolgungsbehörden und Geheimdiensten, glaube ich, sich das Verstehe-Regel genutzt wird.
Der Cantorkel, der auch bei uns, ich weiß nicht, ob das schon mehrmals seine Sendung war, auf jeden Fall hat er darüber auch mal gesprochen, dass er sich über den hamburgischen Datenschutzbeauftragten bei Clearview AI beschwert hat und dadurch das Recht erstritten hat,
dass seine Daten gelöscht werden mussten.
Klavier, ich sag dazu ja jeder der rechtsmäßig in unserer Datenbank drin ist kann gerne darauf hin. Ehr arbeiten das kann sich gerne bei uns melden dann löschen wir das.
Geil das ist deutscher Datenschutz in.
Ähm, Großbrit in den Vereinigten Königreich haben hat Klavier, ich von der britischen Datenschutzbehörde 7,5 Millionen Pfund. Äh, Strafe bekommen und wurde zu löschen aller Daten von Bewohnern.
Das war eigentlich in Königreichs aufgefordert in Italien und Griechenland. Äh, hat Klavier jeweils eine Strafe in Höhe von 20 Millionen Euro bekommen.
So jetzt auch von der Knil, der Datenschutzbehörde, also CNIL, ähm, der Datenschutzbehörde Frankreichs. In die ursprünglich wegen DSGVO Verstoß den eine Mahnung zugesendet hat, die hat, darauf hat Klavier nicht reagiert.
Haben sie jetzt eine Geldstrafe von 20 Millionen verhängt. Außerdem bekommt Klavier noch zwei Monate Zeit, die Ähm, Sammlungen, Speicherung und Verwendungen von Fotos französischer Bürgerin zu beenden und alle bisher gesammelten Daten zu löschen.
Danach werden je weitere 100.000 Euro Strafe fertig für jeden Tag, an dem die Vorgaben nicht umgesetzt werden.
Die Frage ist, wie sie das überprüfen.
Nimmst den Foto vom Franzosen und guckst ob sie dir sagen den haben in unserer Datenbank. Ganz also das geht, das geht glaube ich.
Ich finde es aber tatsächlich mal doch durchaus erstaunlich. Also zwei Dinge finde ich erstaunlich.
Erstens, dass hier einige Länder, die nicht für nennenswerten Datenschutz im internationalen Ruf stehen. Hier sehr viel krasser Vorgehen als Deutschland das tut.
Und zweitens, dass dieses Unternehmen offen bei einer Lage ist, all diese Strafen zu bezahlen.
Ja, ich wollte auch gerade fragen, inwiefern 100.000 Euro pro Tag bei denen überhaupt Schmerz?
Also 100.000 Euro pro Tag, glaube ich, schmerzt schon jedes Unternehmen.
Ja, schon, aber keine Ahnung. Haben auf jeden Fall einiges damit verdient, glaube ich.
Ja, was wiederum zeigt, dass Daten das neue Öl sind. Warte mal, was sind das denn?
Na ja, das wären halt 36,5 Millionen im Jahr, ne? Nur Strafe in Frankreich.
Nur schon ein bisschen was. Und 20 müssen Sie e-zahlen.
Ja, also das könnte jetzt... ... bin mal gespannt. Wahrscheinlich werden sie sich in irgendeiner Form dagegen wenden oder so, aber es ist also zumindest mal...
... positiv hervorzuheben, dass sich hier Bemühungen stattfinden, diesem Geschäftsmodell ein Ende zu bereiten.
So, Zeit wird es ja auch für unseren Schluss.
Genau, es ist jetzt halt.
Könnte ein bisschen schwierig werden unseren takt in den nächsten zwei wochen aufrecht zu erhalten müssen wir mal gucken wie uns das das gelingt
so stehen ein paar reisen an aber wir haben uns ja jetzt schon frisch versorgt schon mal
dann gucken wir mal was passiert.
So machen wir das.
Leute wie ihr seid entlassen. Wir hören uns bald wieder und sagen erst mal Tschüss.
Bis dahin tschau tschau.